[Music]
you love comics you love superheroes you
love superhero movies yeah recent
superhero movies any of them uh oh man
the avengers i've seen like four or five
times now uh is that your is that your
favorite yeah the avengers is amazing
and i was watching it recently uh in
times square and i'm depressed and
sitting in my hotel room and i was like
i don't treat myself and
i was watching the avengers nude um
which is the way you should watch that
movie
like we should have been allowed to have
her out during the theater
come on
why why why why i will tell you
why
why
because when hulk beats a loki that's a
full-on
all right
[Applause]
old
i smash go too close the sensors
the sensor left 20 minutes ago
the sensor left when you pulled up in
your car
he usually shot himself yeah printing
out his resume uh you know what we we
are uh oh man we're out of time uh
well we really are out of time it's not
because you started doing that um
[Applause]
that in and of itself is not offensive
that's just me holding a hand off to the
side of a microphone
which is how i do it uh
i gotta mention immortal
i'll clear the room i'll clear it and
fill it with a blue foam
immortalized i just have to make sure we
get to this immortalize is on amc and
this is a show it's kind of it's
described as the iron chef of taxidermy
so you taxidermist compete yes and we
have our immortalizers we have our four
uh taxidermists and they're really good
at their job and then they we have these
other challengers come on and it's just
like that but now you work with animals
when they don't cook the dead animals
right that's the second show
when they approached you and said we
want to do this show at first you were
reticent yeah because i'm a big animal
lover i got two dogs and two cats and i
just loved animals and then they were
like well
these animals all have died of natural
causes so i was a little bit cooler with
that but i actually wish they'd die
something really cool doing something
really cool like like set their meth lab
on fire
dogs don't have meth labs yours don't
uh immortalized premieres next thursday
at 10 on amc brian's one-hour special
the farthest yes it says right here
it says right here hold up prop
i i went to college
the farthest
hold up prop
is coming soon to netflix